[Music]
it's time to welcome back once again
mr conan o'brien and sonam obsession
hello guys thank you for joining us
well there's no place i'd rather
wait be minute that's a sweet start
wait a minute i'm in hawaii right now oh
right
oh with salma hayek is that where i am
no
i knew there was a catch
i knew there was always a catch i'm
sorry i was under the impression i was
on a hawaiian vacation with sam hayek
and uh then i just remembered it was
with you guys oh this is not i mean i
have to amend what i said earlier
there's another place i'd rather be
good to see you
uh sonia good to see you blai and uh uh
you know i'm here and let's make the
best of it do you like mario are you
familiar what's your stance what's your
stance on mario
you know like all of us i've seen mario
around
uh
in the neighborhood
i was like where where i had some
experience with mario because um when my
son when my daughter and son were
younger they went through a mario phase
and so
i would you know play with them and and
then i had the experience of going to
some convention i think you were there
blai yeah we went to a convention and we
met the voice of mario do you remember
that and the creator of mario yeah we
met you was okay all right i i i
remember
was he came up to me and someone said oh
conan this is the voice of mario and
he did what is it what does mario say
it's me mario yeah so so
i i
they bring this
adult male who's who i think is older
than i he looked to be in his 60s or
something and they go code and this is
the voice of martin went oh hi it's very
nice to meet you you know
congratulations and he went you know i'm
a mario
and i went yeah well congratulations i'm
leaving a pizza pie
and i said oh okay look out here
and i said oh you know like oh
and
he wouldn't just be himself
do you know what i mean mario he
wouldn't let it drop and i kept trying
to talk to him and then i was thinking
like oh you know
he has a meeting with his doctor and his
doctor's like you know we have to talk
because i'm really concerned about i
mean we're going to have to operate
immediately
well no okay yes i know i know but
anyway i think you're going to be fine
but we're going to go through the right
ventricle we're going to put a stent in
and i just thought oh this is bad he's
always doing that i mean yeah i also
love all these classic mario lines
like i'm making a pizza pie well i don't
know what he says look out for the
sledgehammer is that what you said
yeah
but you know like can you imagine being
in a relationship with him and he's
orgasming it's just terrible oh no don't
do it don't do it
here no come on i might
finish oh my god those are those are
some of my favorite mario lines
i will say classic classic mario oh no
oh
how do we even talk about anything else
after this
have you ever actually played any mario
games because i really think you'd like
the last one if i'm honest it takes
place in a kingdom of cats sure uh
mario's random at all suit uh and the
place is called lake lapcat okay lake
lapcat can i ask you is there
an algorithm somewhere that just
randomly
says
is it says random things and that's how
they create these video games because
you said like okay mario you know i know
mario yeah i know all about mario yeah
well guess what now he's in a glenn and
he's a cat and it's called lake
something and i think i could do this
too i could just make up yeah what have
you done with uh what's going on with
mario i got it i'm all i mean what are
these pitch meetings like what do you
got coney got something new tomorrow
yeah yeah he's in a big bowl of soup
what
yeah he's in a big bowl of soup he's in
a submarine that's made out of caramel
and uh his best friend is the uh is the
insert that goes in your shoe
and his name is in certi
and anyway they're trapped in a japanese
gummy bear and uh
their mission is to try and save eleanor
roosevelt i kind of want that to happen
you're actually not far off super mario
odyssey his hat was a sentient hat that
was like a character also of course
doesn't matter yeah
yeah they just all
they literally have an algorithm that
throws out random things talking hat
watch that's constipated uh you know
guitar that uh you know
is fluent in sanskrit and then that
that's the game and everyone's like i
don't know how they do it man
i mean i i will say it does kind of feel
like that with la with the lap cat thing
but also isn't it weird like i i just
have to say like there's a whole
world of people who love mario and and
anything they can do no wrong nintendo
can do no wrong no matter how weird we
get and so
i kind of you know it starts to feel
like nintendo is maybe just trying to
troll their fan base like how far can we
push this how far can we push it we've
got cat land now i submit to you
both
that um
in any cult once you're in and you're in
all the way
the whoever's running the cult
can change the rules and ask for
anything and there's nothing you're just
gonna go along with it so that's what's
happened is once you've devoted seven
eight nine ten years to mario
and you're in
and they start asking more and more of
you you're just gonna go with it you
know until suddenly you're all like
you know living on a on a mountaintop in
utah you know and waiting for a
spaceship to come take you away like
that's that's what this is is that where
the mario franchise is uh is heading
towards yeah they're just slowly
indoctrinating everybody i don't think
that slowly
but at some point they're all going to
go to a mountaintop in utah and the ship
is going to descend at the appointed
time
and a strange creature's going to come
out and call it getting in the ship
[Laughter]
now we're going to have a sex
um he doesn't have to keep going to that
well he's very sex obsessed ruining it
maybe that's the sound he makes when he
orgasms
that's awful when are you
orgasming right well i don't know if
this means i'm going to be playing mario
never again or mario a lot more i think
we both know the answer which is a lot
more
well uh guys if you have a game you want
conan's hot take on hit us up at good
game nice try on twitter uh
thanks conan and thanks
anytime
anytime